hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast exploiting sis regulatory
enhancers as therapeutic targets in
cancer it is presented by Martin Hurst
PhD an associate professor and associate
director at the University of British
Columbia I am Judy O'Rourke of lab roots
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots lab roots is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before I begin I'd like to
remind everyone this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box it
appears on the screen our speaker will
respond to your questions via email if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
in the top right corner of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits please
join me in welcoming dr. Hurst I will
now turn the presentation over to him
well thank you so let's let's get
started so as I hope everyone knows
although your genome is encoded in a
string that's about two meters in length
it's exquisitely packaged into your
nucleus which is a mere few microns and
subject subjected to both heritable and
transient regulatory control and we
understand a number of mechanisms by
which this regulatory control is
maintained through direct modifications
to chromatin chromatin being the
combination of the DNA in the nucleus
Adeem you genome and the proteins that
package it and the proteins that are
packaged it are called histones and
these work together in a unit to a
complex called a nucleosome the
nucleosome itself and those are the
little balls that you'll see in India
and the
why they've been looking at now these
histones packaged within the nuclear
nucleosomes have any terminal tails that
are disordered and these are decorated
with chemical modifications that can act
to reinforce active and repressed States
there are other mechanisms of regulatory
control including regions of the genome
that are open and these are marked in
presentation by these so-called genes
one hypersensitive sites and there are
modifications directly to the DNA itself
this is primarily in at least in
mammalian somatic cells in the context
of cpgs this is DNA methylation so now
that we've added to the CPG but it can
also be a hydroxymethyl and other
oxidative forms we know that RNA which
is also indicated in the slide plays a
role in regulating they have been
epigenetic code through interactions
with the enzymes which act to lay down
these modifications now just to get a
little bit more detail in terms of what
we understand about these epigenetic
modifications of course DNA methylation
has been known was actually was actually
initially discovered only five years
after we after the famous experiments of
a Bree MacLeod and McCartney determined
the DNA to be their predatory agent and
but it some decades of work actually to
to understand the significant role that
DNA methylation plays in differentiation
of cells so what we understand about DNA
methylation today is that CPGs these are
as I mentioned the area within or the
sequence within the mammalian genome
that is methylated I'm see Cochise are
not randomly distributed in the genome
rather they're they're collected in
areas that we call CPG Islands or rich
or CPG rich regions but actually in
these CPG rich regions represent the
ancestral CPG constants of the genome
and over the eons through spontaneous
deamination other CG other CGS have been
lost but these CPG Islands have been
maintained presumably under selective
pressure because they act in a
regulatory way to control the expression
of genes so see VG's are unevenly
distributed mammalian genomes and
actually if you look at a normal somatic
cell the majority of CPGs in your cell
are actually methylated but we do see a
specific decrease correlated with
differentiation and cellular
differentiation and also in specific
cellular contexts we now understand that
gene bodies themselves are methylated
and this is something that is relatively
recently been determined or this the
mechanism is relatively recently been
determined and traditionally or at least
automatically on we've considered
methylation to be associated with gene
repression and this is true but only in
the continent only it's the very
specific context and if you look at the
figure at the bottom of the slide you'll
see some specific patterns of DNA
methylation that I just mentioned so for
example within an active gene body we
see a DNA methylation and with enhancers
we see a hypo methylation or a loss of
methylation and then we also see this
loss of methylation within transcription
factor binding sites which will which
we'll talk about in a little bit more
detail as we go through the through this
presentation today now in addition to
DNA methylation as I mentioned histones
themselves are also modified and when we
know of over a hundred different
modifications that can occur advances in
technology over the last decade have
enabled us to actually measure these
epigenetic features genome-wide using
technologies such as chip sequences of
chromatin immunoprecipitation sequencing
and a number of consortium have used
these technologies to map these marks
genome-wide one of the first of which
was the NIH roadmap consortium we
defined a so called
reference core set of histone
modifications which I'm showing on the
right hand side
sly and these include modifications that
that reinforce both active and as well
as repressive states and other
modifications that are found so shooting
with enhancer enhancer genes as again as
is indicated on the right hand side of
the slide and just as a reference the
way that we the nomenclature that's
developed for referring to histone
modifications is shown there so the
first two letters indicate the histone
in this case histone h3 and then we have
this specific amino acid let's modify
sublicense force okay lysine fourth is
the fourth amino acid from the
n-terminal tail remember that the
n-terminal tail is this unstructured
tail that sticks out of the blue as long
as I showed earlier and then in the
three indicates the the modification in
this case three members and what you can
see is that in fact different types of
modifications occur at the same at the
same amino acids for example h3k27
acetylation mark of an active enhancer
but it can also be trying methylated as
is shown at the bottom and this is
indicated a repressive mark so both
active and repressive chromatin states
exist and these can also be and these
are also used to to discover and to
annotate other regulatory features in
the genome okay so unlike your genome
which is largely the same throughout an
organism's life and in fact is also
largely the same throughout all the
cells in your body with it with the
exception of some specialized immune
cells on the epigenome is distinct and
it's distinct in all of the cell types
of your body so we as far as me we have
determined each cell type each unique
cell type in your body contains unique
at the genetic state and so you can
imagine that this is much more
challenging to determine what these
unique epigenetic states are throughout
all the cell types of your body and even
in even more complexes that we know that
the the epigenome can be modified by
environmental stimulus so different
environmental stimulus can
a genetic signature and that's a dynamic
interface between the environment and
your genes and it also plays a
significant role in in specifying cell
type so as I mentioned there are a
number of consortium who have work who
are working together I'm using
technology again that's been developed
in the last decade to beginning to try
and generate a series of what we call
reference epigenomes
which are meant as a foundational
resource much like the reference human
genome to allow us to begin to
understand what are the patterns
associated or what are the epigenetic
patterns associated with a given cell
type and how do these epigenetic
patterns change as a consequence of
disease
one such consortium is is the Canadian
in a genetics environment and health
research consortium which is a member of
the international human epigenome
consortium the types of data we generate
are shown in this matrix data matrix
here this is on something those of you
who are familiar with for example any
code or the reference mapping activities
would recognize this type of matrix and
here we can see along the top the types
of modifications that are the type of
epigenetic states that are measured and
then along the the rows we can see the
particular cell types that have been
that have been assayed and so really the
goal here is to fill these matrices for
all of the cell types all of the normal
cell types in in the human body as a
reference again to then understand their
dysregulation in disease I'm making the
the arrow indicates a particular
reference that's been generated in this
case where a a well-studied mammary cell
line and CF 1018 Sapphira Pacific's tell
line and I'm just making the point in
the next slide that along with these
reference epigenomes
we have generated a collection of
standardized both sample experiment and
run metadata on that a reveille
through the public repositories for
researchers such as yourself to then
parse this information out and download
these full reference of you genomes for
your own research purposes and again in
the next slide just to make the point
that as as a part of this process we
also link all of the samples to ontology
and these ontology is then allow you to
to do large-scale analysis across these
reference epigenomes
so collectively groups globally are now
working together as part of the
international human epigenome consortium
to generate these reference maps as I
mentioned one of the founding members is
the NIH roadmap program and encode is a
member a for TN as well as the circ
Network and members across here
Indonesia and again the purpose of these
of this consortium is really to generate
these reference maps that can then be
used for for studying diseases these
reference maps have been are published
through public repositories but are also
available or have been published and in
these collections of manuscripts first
within a nature continuum is shown on
the left and more recently within a
package of cell papers and currently the
next iteration is currently being worked
on so so with a sort of primer in terms
of what we understand about the
epigenetics and and our activities
around generating references what do we
understand about epigenetic dysfunction
and disease and in particular I'm going
to focus in today's talk on on cancer so
also one of the one of the the most or
one of the interesting findings that's
emerged after the last decade of
sequencing cancer genomes of course
using the same technology that's allowed
us that is allowing us to measure
epigenetic features has also been
applied to study cancer genomes and one
of the most surprising
was that was the finding that there are
across many types of cancers there are
recurrent on gain and loss of function
mutations to epigenetic modifiers and
these can be really classified in terms
of their frequency so for example in
some cases these these mutations are
pathognomonic they're actually describe
the disease for example in a pediatric
willing to drive a tumor almost a
hundred percent of these tumors are
contained by little applause are
mutations which drive by lytic loss of
an epigenetic modifier called smurfy one
on their recurrence so we see them at
very high frequencies in some steamers
for example glioma we seek a new
function ith mutations in nearly 80% of
low-grade glioma and let me look and now
we can look at very high resolution at a
earlier some preterm pre tumorous
lesions we can see that these epigenetic
modifying mutations are very early
events and I'll talk a little bit more
about that as I go through the
presentation so just to give a few
examples of what I'm talking about so
first of all
rapidly tumors of malignant rothko in
tumors these are really defined since
really a pathognomonic description or a
pathognomonic on mutation and these are
really defined by the viola Lu the
Glossop's marking one and what I'm
showing you here is really just a
compendium of data that's been generated
across a cohort of 47 million
rhabdo tuners and then what you can see
is that on the top row is that the only
commonality here again is loss of smart
big one with the sole exception of one
tumor that that actually has a loss of
smart gate 4 which is another member of
the Sigma complex in this case this
recent complex this is a very aggressive
tumor it happens early in life usually
before 1 year of age and is almost
universally fall so here we have an
example of annotation to an energetic
modifier that drives a very specific
disease in a very specific context
another type of a tumor that appear
to be that appears to be driven by
epigenetic dysfunction is is again a
pediatric tumor in this case of Penta
moma
and this particular tumor is actually
the only tumor that will be so I'm aware
of that appears to not have any genetic
mutations to epigenetic modifiers but
rather appears to just have evidence of
an epigenetic alteration so on the left
hand side we can see a panel which shows
the mutational frequencies across a
series of different tumor types with
ependymoma being at the very bottom and
what you can see is there's essentially
no recurrent mutations that can be found
in this particular tumor type and then
on the right hand side what we can't see
though is that there is a clear
signature so-called signature so this is
a CPG Island methylated phenotype as
it's called where we see a clear a gain
of an methylation with instant CPG
Islands in a subset of ependymoma cases
so again no evidence of genetic lesions
but evidence of epigenetic alterations
associated with disease and as far as
again as far as I'm aware this is the
only tumor type of this class on another
class of tumors and again we're staying
with in pediatric malignancies this is
really pediatric CNS tumors where we see
these mutations not to the epigenetic
modifiers but rather to the internal
tails themselves and these are the the
tails the unstructured tails that are
decorated with these epigenetic
modifications and in fact we can see
mutations directly to the amino acids
that are modified and these are highly
specific so we see specific mutations to
specific amino acids associated with a
subtype of cancer that in type of a
pediatric on the CNS tumor which is a
which emerges in a particular area of
the brain so very highly specific tumors
early in life and again involve some
epigenetic dysfunction however in this
case this is through mutations to the
end
Hotels this stones themselves so another
example is a low-grade glioma and
low-grade glioma are associated with neo
morphix of gain-of-function mutations in
this particular case gain-of-function
mutations to idh1 and in this study
published in 2014 really highlights the
the feature of this early events that I
mentioned earlier so even when we look
in normal tissue that's adjacent to the
to the to the tumor itself on what we
see is mutations this gain-of-function
mutations in idh1 and I'll be talking a
little bit more about this talking a lot
more about this particular mutation as
we go through the slides but suffice it
to say that this mutation leads to
epigenetic dysfunction and is found both
early and then if we look along these
trees so on the left hand side and the
right hand side there are two different
patients where we tracked the mutations
that occur in each of these tumors and
what you can see is that these mutations
are very early so they're in the blue
bars you can see they're actually
present in the adjacent normal tissue
but then also as we look through through
the history or the as the tumor has
evolved these idh mutations are in fact
you bigger this so they're found in all
of the recurrence of the tumor and also
very early in the tumor progression so
finally another type of tumor in this
case we're talking about a liquid tumor
and in this case acute myeloid leukemias
so acute myeloid leukemias have are
associated with a large number of
mutations to epigenetic modifications of
modifiers and in fact if we just look at
the class of mutations that affect DNA
methylation and those are the ones that
I boxed in red in this figure we can see
that nearly 44 percent of de novo a.m.
House contain a mutation to one or more
enzyme that controls antinea methylation
homeostasis so this include
in the top row and again looking at this
figure the the rows in this particular
instance indicate genes and the columns
are individual patients and then the
colors indicate where a mutation has
occurred and so what you can see is that
if you look in the red boxed area you
can see a series of enzymes the first
the first three are the DMT so these are
the enzymes that are responsible for
laying down methylation to these methyl
transferases first two being the de novo
and then we have the maintenance and
then we have a ten enzymes Tet one and
two and these are enzymes that are
responsible for removing methylation so
they involved in hydroxyl methylation
and then either through active or
passive mechanisms leads to the DNA
demethylation and finally again the IDH
enzymes and again these are the same
gain-of-function mutations that we see
associated with glioma and as you'll see
these ideas mutations actually act upon
tech to one other point i'd like to
point out is that when we do see these
Tet or idh mutations these are mutually
exclusive in other words we don't see
them together in the context of heute
myeloid leukemias so just to kind of
reiterate that point and give a little
bit more detail and the next slide now
I'm showing you the mechanism by which
DNA methylation homeostasis is
maintained so you can see on the left
hand side we have DNA that's methylated
so you can see a cytosine that's
methylated and tattoo through alpha
ketoglutarate then hydroxy methylates
the cytosine and then either through an
active mechanism through base excision
repair or through a through a passive
mechanism in other words through
cellular differentiation the methylation
that that was initially present and
shown on the left hand side is then
washed so tattoo and the Tet family so
there's three at once at tune in check
three are responsible for removing
methylation in the genome now the gang
of function mutations idh generates
instead of generating
alpha-ketoglutarate a generation on
metabolite called two hydroxy butyrate
and two hydroxy butyrate acts upon the
tet enzymes and actually inhibits them
and so you so the gain of function
mutation of idh phenol copies though the
mutations attempt to through or the loss
of function mutation to tattoo leading
to its inhibition and as i just
mentioned in the context of acute
myeloid leukemias when we see either
texting mutation or ibh we don't see
them together and curiously for reasons
that we don't fully understand in the in
the context of gliomas we only see the
idh mutation and just to finally mention
that the the - I Drive Safely rate is
also capable or is also it's also
capable of inhibiting lysine
demethylation so the way that we move
methyl groups from from from histones as
is indicated at the top of this figure
also goes through a hydroxy methylation
step the lysine demethylases and two
hydroxyl butyrate has been shown to
inhibit these as well okay so the tenons
ons as i as i just introduced are
actually part of a family of two oxy
blue turi
dependent oxygen X's so and I'm showing
in this in this slide I'm showing you a
file engine or a dendogram of the of the
two oxy blue very dependent oxygen oozes
and you can see in the blue color here
there's the text so these are the
nucleic new nucleotide hydroxyl drops
the laces and then you can see in the
yellow and the green and the purple on
these are all the histone demethylases
so these are the KTMs the juban G's for
example and then in the grave you can
see some prolene hydroxy laces and so
these are another class of hydroxyl aces
in encoded in the genome now what we
know is one hydroxylase that is perhaps
well known is actually the cause of the
beige and screwed so-called prolene
hydroxylase and prolyl hydroxylase
which is shown on the right of this
figure is responsible for hydroxylated
collagen and these this hydroxyl form is
required to form collagen fibers and of
course in the absence of vitamin C
vitamin C being and essential nutrients
and achievements or in in humans and
primates than the absence of vitamin C
the side rocks in this hydroxy
methylation does not occur and you get
collagen breakdown so what vitamin C is
is required for this reaction and it
acts to reduce iron and and and this
reduction is required for for active
probing hydroxylation so so given this
and given that 10 is a is one as a
member of the same family and we asked
some some years ago whether whether it
would be possible for vitamin c to also
enact upon other dioxygen uses for
example the 10 and so what's being shown
in this figure in panel a is
immunohistochemistry of in this case
from uranium trionic stem cells
following vitamin c treatment and
culture and then doing
amina histah chemistry against
hydroxymethyl cytosine and what you can
see is that after 12 hours of treatment
you can see a large gain or a gain in
hydroxy methylation is as indicated in
the signal if you look on the lower
panel you can what is shown here is
actually a quantification of this change
genome why and now we're looking at a
particular gene here and what we can see
is that there's actually a dynamic
response to the addition of vitamin c so
starting in the untreated at the top you
can see hydroxy methylation at 12 hours
with the blue density the blue track and
what you can see is that after 12 hours
you get a gain in in hydroxy methylation
and then in the maroon tracks underneath
you can see that in the untreated state
in fact there's a gene is
we methylated on the CGS are shown at
the very bottom those are the slashes
the black slashes but you can see that
this gene is heavily methylated when
it's untreated and then after 72 hours
becomes unmethylated so putting this
together what we what we're what we what
we observed is that following vitamin C
treatment we see a gain of hydroxy
methylation at the gene and this leads
to a subsequent DNA methylation event
that occurs at 72 hours I'm so
consistent with a model where vitamin C
might be activating the 10 enzyme
leading to this hydroxy methylation
event and then the DA plot on the right
hand side just shows this again in a
quantitative measure showing the gain of
hydroxy methylation following button C
treatment so so I've already told you
that vitamin C is required for reduction
of iron which is required for the two
hydroxy butyrate dependent oxygen Aizaz
however there's also some evidence in
vitro for direct interaction between
vitamin C and and the ten enzymes so
again looking at the top panel you can
see that when we add vitamin C to media
and when we add vitamin C in vitro we
can see activation in this case of a
protein hydroxylase this was data
generated many years ago and this was
then replicated on below in this case
looking at tattoo and we can see that
but by adding so this is the lower panel
on the left side by adding vitamin C we
can see induction and tattoo activity
whereas if we had other reducing agents
such as TTT or who define we don't see
that activity again suggesting that
perhaps there's something distinct about
vitamin C's ability to activate tattoo
and indeed around the same time that our
paper was was published another showed
that using an intrinsic fluorescence
measurement that there appears or
suggests that there might be a direct
interaction between
see and tattoo so you can see on the
right panel that vitamin C Edition used
induces a change in this intrinsic
fluorescence which is suggestive of a
direct interaction perhaps between
vitamin C and tattoo so what do we know
about vitamin C in terms of its activity
or its distribution in the body well of
course it's it's been studied for many
years and has been measured in blood
serum and in looking at the top
left-hand side this is a panel looking
at or this is a panel showing ascorbic
acid in the blood and what we know is
that is that ascorbic acid her vitamin
C's levels in the plasma is tightly
regulated so on the x-axis we can see a
dose per day so the Ordos milligrams per
day and then on the y-axis we can see
the plasma concentration in my combat so
what you can see is that you quickly
plateau and then just increasing the
amounts of more vitamin C at least
orally doesn't mean to any increase in
the plasma concentrations in fact this
the the additional vitamin C is simply
excreted now what's curious and on the
right-hand panel at the top on what I'm
showing you is a publication from 2011
which showed that actually when we look
within monocytes and other blood cell
types we actually see an increased
concentration of vitamin C so now I'm
going from through low an animal or high
man multi-micro mole sorry from my
caramel to millimolar concentrations so
we can actually see that within
monocytes we're actually reaching
through between 3 & 4 milli more
concentrations by MHC again suggesting
that vitamin C's being actively pumped
into these cell types and actually being
concentrated this was recently confirmed
and then extended by a Sean Morrison's
group pig publishing last fall I'm
showing that if you actually
breakdown the chemo chemo blood cell
types into chemo aquatic progenitor cell
types such as HSCs and Multi progenitor
cell types you actually see that the
increase in vitamin C concentration is
associated with these progenitor stem
cell-like cells so this is shown on the
bottom left panel and under the right
panel what you can see is the
concentration of ascorbate within these
cells is actually directly correlated
not surprisingly to the expression of a
transporter that transport vitamin C and
so you can see again in the right top
right-hand quadrant of the bottom right
figure you can see this gain of vitamin
C in the hematopoietic progenitor
population so taking this all together
we asked whether or we conjecture
well maybe given what I told you about
Ted inactivation in the context of acute
myeloid leukemia either through a gain
of function mutation to idh which
directly inhibits tattoo or through a
direct genetic mutation to tattoo we
asked well well or we conjecture maybe
or could write immense e to overcome
this inhibition and directly a reverse
epigenetic alterations that are
associated with these either the gain of
function or loss of function mutations
gain of function ith or loss of function
mutations to TechSoup now looking back
in the literature we can see that in the
late 80s or early 90s a study actually
looked at the the consequence of adding
ascorbic acid to cultures to either
looking at normal hemopoietic cell types
or myelodysplastic cells these are
pre-mixed State or can lead to frank
transformation and then looking at
Frankie McGrath and asking what is the
consequence of adding ascorbic acid to
the media and what you can see is that
in many cases and that's along the
dotted line here there was really no
change
in the song but there was a set of
leukemic cells that responded to to the
ascorbic acid and one my conjecture that
the ones that responded and may in fact
be that set of leukemia cells that
contain an activating mutations to tear
or gain-of-function mutations to ID h so
we set out to directly test this in this
case using a a leukemic model so in this
model we take bone marrow cells from
your mouse and we immortalize them using
a well known conquer gene hoxsey 9 and
that's shown so in the in the left-hand
panel we immortalize them using hoxsey 9
and then we add to these immortalized
cells either wild-type idh so this is
just the IDH wild-type form or a gain of
function mutation this is indicated
here's idea to mute and on the left-hand
panel so panel a we can show that when
we add the hoxsey 9 idh mutation we
indeed you can see production of 2
hydroxyl iterator again this is the
uncle metabolites that inhibit step 2
and then on the right-hand panel on the
far right column panel C we can see that
indeed by introducing idh mutants into a
hoxsey 9 background or oxalate night
transformed bone marrow cells and we can
see that we need needs to a much reduced
legacy into the keen transformations in
the mouse model so we asked whether we
could by simply adding vitamin C in the
context of this model could we indeed
induce hydroxyl methylation and indeed
McKennon in the top panel which is
probably hard to see but you can see in
the meanest chemistry these and Daffy
are using that on anybody against
5-hydroxymethylcytosine you can see an
increase after 12 hours of addition of
vitamin C and in the lower panel this is
quantified as a percentage of the hmm C+
cells I mean you can see that indeed we
see a significant gang in hydroxy
methylation in the context of this model
through the addition of my
see we with we then went on to see to
show or to show whether this gaining of
hydroxy methylation would in fact
dependent upon tech and we did that
using a tattoo si RNA and this is work
that was published a last summer in
leukemia and on the lower right hand
panel it's just a student in my lab math
you mean gay we did the majority of this
work and what we can see is that by
adding this shRNA mean fax see a
statistical reduction in the amount of
gaining as measured by mean fluorescence
by mystic chemistry of hydroxymethyl
hydroxy methylation so we show that at
least this gain of hydroxy methylation
is at least in part dependent upon the
presence of tattoo so we then went on to
confirm this result further by
generating a CRISPR tattoo knock out
some knocking out excellent one of
tattoo and again what we can see so on
the on this on this panel you can see
the light gray bar is the control so
this is the Hawks a9 gain-of-function
are 132 H idh mutation and then we can
see by addition of vitamin C we see a
gain of intensity that's the dark gray
bar and then by knocking out on the
excellent one we can see the decade is
largely lost again suggesting that at
least in part this gain of hydroxy
methylations being mediated through
through direct directly through tattoo
and then the further bars along in this
figure show the consequence of adding
other DNA demethylation agents in
combination with fibers in combination
with vitamin C so this includes five
Lisa 17 currently a current treatment of
late stage AML as well as doc a deoxy
deoxy form of 5 in society so what
happens to the cells themselves in the
presence of vitamin c so on the left
hand panel here we can see on the top
this is Hawks
I eat wild like grown in either the
presence of control or in the presence
of or in the presence of the carrier or
in the presence of vitamin C and what we
can see is that there's very little
change however when we look at the
hoxsey 9r1 in 32 H we can see that we
see a cytostatic behavior I mean in fact
when we look as shown on the right-hand
panel on what we can see is evidence of
differentiation so looking at the
right-hand panel the lower right
quadrant we can see what appears to be
granular cells or grinding the sites on
the forming when we add vitamin C in the
context of the IDH idh are 132 h hops
8-iron model
so we next looked at the molecular
signature associated with addition of
vitamin c and indeed as we had seen in
the as was evident in the previous slide
we can see when we look when we when we
try to quantitate the the degree of
differentiation as is shown in panel C
here we can see that we see a loss of
progenitor markers such as skull one and
then a gang of differentiation markers
Mac one and gr one I'm suggesting that
addition of vitamin C is indeed
providing a push towards differentiation
in panel D we can show the differential
gene expression I'm following vitamin C
treatment and we can see that we see of
gain of expression so we see more genes
being expressed as a consequence of
vitamin C addition and when we look at
what those cells what pathway those
genes that are being upregulated fall
into you can see that there that there
are pathways that are highly relevant to
differentiation leukocyte regulation and
leukocyte differentiation again
suggesting that an addition of vitamin c
is specifically driving a
differentiation of this particular model
so we next then when looked in the
genome to see what epigenetic state
changes were occurring and what we what
could see is that indeed we could see
gains of hydroxy methylation is a
consequence of vitamin C as we had shown
with our immunised chemistry and we
could see that these gains of hydroxy
methylation occurred specifically at
regions that had gained methylation as a
consequence of transformation of ie HR
132 H so on the left hand panel here
what we're showing is regions that are
these are the regions that were that
gaining methylation when we so we have
our control without with the wild-type
ideation and we have our ID HR 132 H
which results in a gain of methylation
and when we look at those particular
regions we can see by adding vitamin Z
we see this gain of hydroxy methylation
specifically at those regions that
gained methylation as a consequence of
transformation with ID h are 132 H when
we look at the machines that are
associated with the regions in the
genome that are associated with the
regions in the genome that show this
gain of hydroxy methylation on these all
again are associated or these are
associated with genes that are involved
in hemostasis involved in myeloid cell
differentiation again suggesting that
this change in methylation is leading to
a drive towards differentiation so we
next looked at this at the genetic
signature or a motif that was associated
with these regions that gain hydroxy
methylation and lost methylation and
what we saw is that these were enriched
for highly enriched with motifs that
balance transcription factors that are
that are known to be involved in in
mediating or involved in drive our key
transcriptional regulators that Hema
product differentiation including tu one
which is shown at the top on the left
panel and rungs one and it should be
noted that a p1 has previously been
reported to actually interact directly
with Ted and in particular with tattoo
as I mentioned
3sat family members tet1 tattooing Tech
three within our milah within our model
and and also within primary AM L only
Tech's who in step three are highly
expressed intent to itself is the only
one of the three family members that
doesn't have its own DNA binding
movement so it's lacking the CF sexy
domain which is used by tech 1 and T 3
I'm to be recruited to DNA and so but
what has been shown is that tattoo
actually physically interacts and is
recruited to DNA the interactions with
transcription factors as I'm showing in
this cartoon on the right hand side so
p1 is recruited via this motif and then
tattoo again is interacts directly on
leading to the hydroxy methylation of
that particular element when we look at
genome-wide so now knowing that we have
this relationship between p1
transcription factor and the regions
that pain hydroxy methylation following
vitamin C we repeated that experiment
but this time we didn't see against the
p1 itself and what we can see is that
when we add up when we do to seek we can
see that we see a decrease binding of
pu.1 following vitamin C treatment and
this is enriched in regions that were
induced or that lost teeny methylation
following following following vitamin C
treatment and so what we're showing here
is that in the untreated state you can
see that there's significantly more p1
binding sites following and then
following a vitamin C treatment and
there are some that are maintained and
then there's only a very small fraction
only 1.8% shown here that are that are
mean that are unique to the vitamin C
treatment suggesting that perhaps maybe
p1 is being recruited to its methylated
element with more affinity than it is to
the hydroxymethyl a development we see
the exact opposite when we look at wrong
Swan and runks one is a transcription
factor that that is whose binding is
inhibited by methylation and in
what we see is that we see an increase
in runs finding following vitamin C
treatment so again I'm looking at the
left-hand panel here these are regions
in the genome that are found by p1 bye
bye bye wrong spawn by chips T and what
you can see is that we see a large gain
of rungs when binding following vitamin
C treatment suggesting perhaps that the
vitamin C leading to hydroxy leading to
the hydroxy methylation or the binding
of pu.1 recruiting tet2 leading to
hydroxy methylation is then allowing for
wrongful in recruitment and so this is
the model that describes that so again
at the top here on these tp1 which is
balanced to methylated DNA and recruits
teksu and in the presence of this
gain-of-function ibh are 132 a mutation
shown on the left on the top left hand
side of the slide on leads to the
innovation of Tatsu and then the pro
differentiation genes are then not
transcribed but I think vitamin C we're
overcoming this block leading to the
hydroxy methylation of these methylated
regions and then this is leading to the
DNA demethylation which is allowing
rungs one to be recruited to these
elements which is then driving
transcription of the pro differentiation
genes that I showed you in the gene
expression analysis and so this is the
model which we're currently trying to
validate in a context of human PDX
models now after we published our paper
number two papers were published which
showed similar features but in this case
looking at tattoo so instead of looking
in the context of a gain-of-function idh
mutation looking in the context of
direct tattoo in a direct tattoo
inactivation and showing that tattoo and
activation
blocks self-renewal and kina progression
progression and that ascorbic acid has
actually involved in regulating heme
apply on stems
function in genius and leukemia Genesis
so in this particular figure taken from
the second paper so what is being shown
here is another mouse model but in this
case instead of using the Hawks a9 model
or proxy 9 a monkey gene using the Flip
3 IDT so this is another known recurrent
mutation that occurs in the context of
gino-hall
an imbalance and is associated with
transformation in the context of either
a tattoo an activating mutation or ADH
but in this case when we have a tattoo
in activation and with ID h and we
introduce that into a mouse that has
lost the ability to generate vitamin c
so most rodents can generate vitamin c
at de novo but we can generate a rodent
line of luo negative Roden from google
negative Mouse that isn't even capable
of generating vitamin C and when we
introduce these these this leukemic
model or these leukemic cells into the
negative Mouse is shown on in panel B
here you can see that you've got this
dramatic reduction in latency in the
context of the loss of vitamin C so this
is consistent with what we had showed in
the context of the Hoxie 9 ID in charla
13 model around the same time another
paper was published by Peter Jones's
group which actually looked at vitamin C
levels in patients who were suffering
from a hematopoietic malignancy and was
surprised to find actually that a
majority of patients who were undergoing
treatment were actually were actually
shown to be vitamin D deficient so
that's shown in the top panel here shown
in panel a in panel B basically showing
that within looking in patients with
these hematology malignancies actually
that there was this reduction in vitamin
C in the plasma and this finding in its
in its own right has led to the to a
clinical trial which is actually looking
at just oral supplementation in the
context of fiveaces said in treatment in
acute myeloid leukemia patients
and the lower panel here I'm reporting
and the results of another study which
has looked in elderly or elderly patient
on patient subjects who are asymptomatic
but who contain or who looking at their
looking at genetic mutations and their
blood so essentially deeply sequencing
genomic DNA extracted from their blood
I'm actually show these mutations again
Seth to the IDH or ten enzymes at some
frequency cities are elderly patients
who have essentially asymptomatic but
have evidence of low-frequency mutations
on to either idh or tech - and in fact
these low-frequency mutations in the
context of body agent a - have been
shown to be associated with clonal
hemolysis which is it's also associated
with aging suggesting like in the glioma
model that these mutations that are
occurring - these epigenetic modifiers
were actually occurring very early there
they occur very early events perhaps
setting the stage or for further
transformation so some questions that
are arising from from this work is
plenty sufficient vitamin C in its own
right to lay low no hemopoiesis
progression so in the context of those
elderly patients that have these
mutations perhaps just sufficient
vitamin C would would delay the
progression from a clonal hemopoiesis to
their MVS or AML
and finally or can fight Kevin fighting
Kent vitamin C in the context of five
days of cited knee again this is a
standard of care for for MDS and
refractory AML can can vitamin C axon or
gistic Levi has decided me on to lead to
increased DNA demethylation and
therapeutic opportunities and so as I
mentioned earlier horse vitamins inside
of Dean acts as a nonspecific DNA
inhibitor Dana
phrases so maybe the additional evidence
you can accent artistically and in fact
in the context of our um we're now
starting or starting to actually monitor
vitamin C levels in patients who are
undergoing five is this I thinking
treatment locally to see whether we can
replicate on this loss of or this
reduction in vitamin C in the context of
chemo quiet malignancies so finally just
to summarize what I have said so vitamin
C treatment is cytostatic and induces
hypo methylation in these regulatory
regions so these are regions within the
genome that are bound by transcription
factors and also within CPG Island
flanks in the context that the idh1 are
132 H model when we see transcriptional
and regulatory state changes associated
with vitamin C treatment and this these
changes suggest a reactivation of a mile
of differentiation program in the
context of acute myeloid leukemia and
that vitamin C appears to activate
specific two hydroxy butyrate dependent
oxygen aces including Tet as I showed
and then finally that vitamin C may
provide a model for a new class of
epigenetic therapeutics so finally I
just like to thank the individuals who
have who have done the work and also the
funding that that allow this work to be
done and so as I mentioned Matthew Ming
gay and drove the majority of the work
that I talked about as well as many
other folks in the lab and I'd also like
to thank Michael Kaiser for the mouse
model and 20 E's and Keith Humphries as
well as the group at the genome Sciences
Center who have been involved in
generating the reference maps which I
introduced in my talk and we thought I'd
be happy to answer any questions thank
you dr. Hurst for that informative
presentation we will now start the Q&A
portion of the webinar and we'll address
some of the most commonly asked
questions by our viewers if you have any
questions you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question
drop-down box located on the far left of
your presentation window type your
questions into the box that appears on
the screen and click the send button our
speaker will follow up with your
questions via email
let's get started our first question is
with vitamin C be effective in other
cancers which Harbor gain-of-function
idh mutations yes is an excellent
question and of course one such cancer
would be glioma which is another cancer
subtype or we see highly recurrent on
gain-of-function idh mutations and in
fact we've looked to see in a glioma
model whether vitamin C and culture acts
to or drives a gain of hydroxyl
methylation and indeed we do see that
it's also interesting to note that
glioma and AML are both show.this the
same deregulation of their epigenome so
they both saw this gain of methylation
of CPG Islands which is associated with
a presence of this idh mutation so we
need to suggest that perhaps I didn't
see might be might have some therapeutic
I have a therapeutic action in the
context of leiana's thank you next one
is why are somatic mutations -
epigenetic modifiers so specific in
cancer subtypes so this is an excellent
question I think is really one that that
the field is really grappling this so
you know I introduced a series of
different types of epigenetic
modifications that we can talk about for
example loss of smart b1 in the context
of malignant rap toy tubers so this
particular mutation gives rise to a
tumor type that's very specific to - for
example in in the context of MRT to
solve tissues like the kidney and it
arises around the same age and all of
these patients and it's highly specific
we don't see this type of mutation or at
least we don't see this by allelic loss
in other anything other sub type of
cancer suggesting that it's highly
specific and I think that you know the
current sort of thoughts on this is that
the epigenetic state of the cell of
origin in which this genetic mutation
occurs is is various
and that epigenetic state is what allows
for or when when that mutation occurs on
then drives the malignancy and so this
specificity is probably or is likely a
consequence of both the cell of origin
on when in this particular genetic
mutation occurs and the particular
genetic mutation itself on leading to
the types of specificities that we see
although really this is an active area
of research and many of us are trying to
understand what so what role the cell of
origin plays or even what the cell of
origin is just to mention that for many
of the tumors that I just introduced the
cell of origin is not known it's not
known for lignin travel a tumors it's
not known for it and the moma and it's
certainly not known for for any of the
other houston mutant tumors well thank
you for that we have time for one more
question
are there examples of purely
epigenetically driven cancers that's an
excellent question so of course the
reason yeah you know I think in the
public I'm sort of understanding about
you know next something one of the most
exciting things this concept of
interaction between the environment that
you're somehow our environment is can be
encoded with your epigenome and this
might then be inherited you know even
transgenerational but it is interesting
to note that even though we find lots of
evidence and there are many kinds of
cancers that have genetic mutations to
epigenetic modifiers there's only one
and in this case and it's the one that I
introduced ependymoma is the only case
of a cancer that appears to have no
recurrent mutations to genetic modifiers
none that we just haven't seen it yet
but today there's been there really is
no evidence that purely epigenetic
changes can drive a malignancy and so
again it may be that we haven't looked
in the right places or or simply that
this is a feature of
deregulation on that doesn't doesn't in
fact lead to transformation I would like
to once again thank dr. Hurst for his
presentation would also like to thank
laberd's for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I wanna
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through January 11th 2019 you'll receive
an email from lab roots letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
when your colleagues who may have missed
today's event that's all for now thank
you for joining us we hope to see you
again soon bye